for the past month and a half
Business Insider senior retail
correspondent Kate Taylor has been
traveling around Asia and is now in
Australia
I played the work trip to travel around
Asia well before the coronavirus here is
what she's seen in airports and on
planes in response to the corona virus
outbreak and what she's been doing to
travel safer it's been an interesting
time traveling right now when it's
definitely heightened anxiety people are
trying really hard to stay safe not get
sick but it's gonna be ending in self
quarantine for me no matter what happens
I started out in South Korea went to
Vietnam Malaysia Thailand I've been
surprised by how busy the airports I've
been to happen I've been to airports in
Seoul and Ho Chi Minh City and colon
horror and in Phuket so all those
airports I would say are still
definitely seeing people come through
when I was in Seoul that was before the
outbreak really spread in South Korea so
that might have changed by now but in
general I would say that people are
definitely still traveling I just flew
from Phuket to Brisbane and I was
surprised by how crowded that flight was
so I would say that some flights are
definitely a little bit emptier than
usual but it's not as striking as I
might have thought it would be the
biggest thing that I've been noticing is
the temperature texts I flew through
Singapore to get to Brisbane Airport and
there were several different med
stations set up where they were kind of
monitoring people's temperatures as they
walked down the hallway so that was
something I hadn't seen before I know
that that is kind of more common
practice at different airports outside
the u.s. already so not necessarily only
lytic or virus and then people have been
randomly pulled aside to have their
temperature check at different airports
I haven't had my temperature trick that
that many airports but I have had to
have
your try to check into some hotels as
I've been traveling a lot of flight
attendants that I've been seeing all
traveling have been wearing and asks I
would say basically the vast majority
have worn masks so that is pretty much a
standard at this point it seems like
someone wearing gloves as well the
biggest and I think probably the most
effective thing I've been doing for it
myself
is sanitizing my seat every time I sit
down so having some Lysol wipes Clorox
wipes just do sanitizing wipes and wipe
down the entire area before starting the
flight
I felt pretty self conscious when I
started doing this just cuz I was
carrying around a huge thing of wipes
and I felt like it seemed rude but that
is something that I haven't seen more
and more people doing on flights and
actually has been proven to kind of keep
things playing reduce the chance of
getting sick and whenever you have a
chance just go and actually wash your
hands in the bathroom instead of just
relying on hand sanitizer so safely and
not just be aware and if you're next to
someone who's coughing esthetician
receipts I haven't had to do that yet
but that's probably a good rule of thumb
if the CDC says it safe to travel
somewhere then I'm kind of accepting
their judgement at this point I've felt
pretty safe during my traveling I can't
do everyone I can't tell people what to
do but I felt safe traveling around to
all these different measures with
coronavirus cases we'll see if I'm naive
up
I would definitely get tickets you can
refund whatever possible
I have probably lost a good amount of
money on this trip by getting
non-refundable tickets so that is a
mistake that I have made a couple times
basically the situation is changing by
the hour instead of by the week or by
the day at this point so something that
seems entirely safe one day this
situation could change is something
that's not super safe in just a couple
of days
[Music]